après quasiment quatre heures de
négociations l'otan et la russie n'ont
donc pas réussi à trouver un terrain
d'entente aujourd'hui des négociations à
bruxelles jugé crucial qui coince
toujours sur la question de l'extension
l'otan et la crise ukrainienne on
retrouve notre correspondante à moscou
mais lisse d'estrées bonsoir ellis une
dernière rencontre donc prévu pour même
demain viennent les aujourd'hui une
chose est sûre tout est resté bloqué
bonsoir stéphanie effectivement à
l'instar de la rencontre russo
américaines organisé ce lundi à genève
pas de réelles avancées lors du conseil
otan russie d'aujourd'hui et des accords
qui oppose les deux parties sont telles
que celles ci reconnaissent elles-mêmes
ne pas encore savoir comment les
résoudre les tensions restent très
fortes entre la russie et l'occident
washington et ses alliés craignent une
invasion de l'ukraine par moscou en
raison de mouvements de troupes russes à
la frontière russo ukrainienne la russie
tout en démentant fermement une telle
intention et exigent des garanties que
le temps ne s'élargit raffin vers l'est
et ne déploiera pas de missiles près de
ses frontières lors d'une conférence de
presse à l'issue du conseil otan russie
le vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a reproché à l'alliance
atlantique de chercher à atteindre la
supériorité dans tous les domaines et
dans tous les théâtres d'opérations
militaires
écoutez
donc la discussion d'aujourd'hui était
ouverte direct approfondie
riche mais en même temps cette
discussion a mis au jour un certain
nombre de divergences sur des questions
fondamentales
et une de ces question principale c'est
que l'otan
considèrent le principe d'indivisibilité
de
la sécurité de façon tout à fait
alternative de façon tout à fait
sélective et comme je le dis ils ne
prennent pas en compte les intérêts de
sécurité des autres pays
et pour nos l'indivisibilité de la
sécurité doit concerner tout le monde
où la sécurité ne doit pas se faire
contre la russie et ce en la contournant
sinon elle est vouée à l'échec
et si l'otan passez une politique de
dissuasion ça veut dire que ce sera une
politique pour nous deux contres
dissuasion et une politique
d'intimidation nous réagirons de la même
façon
si elle le système des défenses y sont
mis en place contre là aussi ça veut
dire que nous chercherons aussi ce n'est
pas notre choix mais en tout cas
si nous ne parvenons pas à
modifier l'évolution actuelle 1
de son côté le secrétaire général de
l'otan a également souligné cette
divergence entre la russie et l'alliance
qui selon lui seront difficiles à
surmonter il voit toutefois un signal
positif dans le fait qu'un dialogue ait
lieu aujourd'hui
cette discussion n'a pas été facile mais
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
elle était si importante
les alliés de l'otan sur incident sur
les perspectives de progrès de ces
pourparlers
ils se sont déclarés gravement préoccupé
par le renforcement des forces
militaires russes en ukraine et dans ses
environs et ont appelé moscou à
désamorcer immédiatement la situation
ainsi qu'à respecter la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de ses voisins
également appelé la russie à s'abstenir
de tours saussure de force agressive que
de toutes activités malveillantes à
l'encontre des alliés c'est à respecter
l'ensemble de ses obligations et
engagements internationaux
cela signifie que notre dialogue tout
cela signifie que notre dialogue est
difficile mais plus que jamais
nécessaire
les alliés de l'otan ont fusé manière
qui ne les ménagera aucun effort pour
trouver une issue politique
du côté américain la secrétaire d'état
adjointe wendy sherman a déclaré colotte
l'otan ne renoncerait pas à sa politique
de portes ouvertes mais que cela
n'empêchait pas à la russie et
l'alliance atlantique de coopérer dans
certains domaines une chose est sûre en
tout cas la russie et l'occident
comptent poursuivre leur dialogue via
les canaux diplomatiques et militaires
les pourparlers entre représentants
russes européens et américains se
poursuivront dès ce jeudi cette fois ci
à vienne dans le cadre de l'organisation
pour la sécurité et la coopération en
europe on suivra évidemment merci à ma
liste des stray en direct de moscou